well it looks like Hillary Clinton's
emails couldn't be the subject of more
FBI probing oh my right still for that
mid probe
first of all why she have that face with
the headline Weiner above it
oh so it's FBI the federal beef
injection and now the hashtag Hillary
for prison is trending yes with the typo
in fact it's been trending for two days
and he's at the top of the treads in two
entirely days to say what you want about
Hillary's emails at least they were
spell checked this is the biggest
political typo since 1948 when the
newspapers mistakenly reported Dewey
beats off Truman
some people are claiming that prison was
spelled that way on purpose to avoid
Twitter censors these are the same
people that thought xhampster was a
medical pet care website Hillary for
Prison comedians what is prison April
that's how you spell prison the
dictionary is rigged
alright boy it's not a typo at all
that's Hillary's rap name frizzy y'all
it is musical prison is a Vegas DJ that
gave my sister a urinary tract and she
calls her vagina Hilary